okay it's just preparing the livestream
okay should now be like okay thanks Alex
afternoon and everybody welcome to our
first zoom executive meeting so bear
with me as we try and work through the
challenges of the technology so just by
way of opening up the meeting just to
advise and by way of attendance and
apologies that I've received apologies
from councillor Freeman I also learned
that councillor Hines is trying to get
into the meeting but he's having some
technical challenges and also that both
sorry Todd and niki bishop from the
corporate leadership team are not able
to join us today
the second item on the agenda is
questions from members public and I can
confirm that none have been received the
the format for the meeting I think just
just before we move into the
declarations of interest and substantive
items I spurred the guide that was sent
out to members and if you just
familiarize yourself with the
participant list which he can bring up
at the bottom there is the raise hand
option so if you would like to come in
on any of the items if you could raise
your hand I am conscious that we do need
to finish the meeting in good time and
there are a lot more members on the core
than would usually be the case but I
will give an indication that I need to
limit speakers if we reach that point in
time and ask the group leaders to
confirm who they would like to speak
when ISIL shouldn't agree if we need to
do that so just turning to item 3 on the
agenda other any declarations of
interest in any items on the agenda and
if so could you raise your hand in the
participant list and I will bring you in
please
okay that's great thank you
item four there are four sets of minutes
including both the budget executive and
a special meeting of the executive as
well as those more typical meetings
there could I ask members of the
executive if they're happy to receive
and approve those minutes please and I
will ask you to take yourself off mute
just compliment that's okay please item
5 is standing on the agenda matters from
the overview and scrutiny committees so
obviously members will be aware that at
the beginning of the corona virus
outbreak a decision was taken to suspend
our more usual scrutiny proceedings and
week since established a pandemic
scrutiny committee chaired by councilor
axon and I just wondered councilor otter
there was anything you wanted to say
about the work of the committee at this
point yes thank you Andrew can you hear
me yes and yeah we have actually
submitted a short report to the
executive you may not have received it
yet as it was only sent to you I think
this afternoon and but it's with regard
to the work of the fund demek scrutiny
committee that's been carried out since
the establishment of the committee in
May the committee has now met twice the
first meeting discussed the functions
and the operations of the committee and
also identified which topics we wish to
prioritize for the committee for the
second meeting which was held last
Monday on the 15th of June the members
set out a number of written questions
for the relevant executive members and
officers and public health officer and
the questions they explored a range of
topics around the headliner public
health adult social care and schools and
education and within those topics our
questions related to test track and
trace system pandemic impact on the Bane
community the impact of government
amendments to the Care Act on both
education and social care adult and
children's mental health and children
returning to school and the impact of
vulnerable children on their education
through this pandemic and child minders
and child care and looked after children
so there's a lot of topics and I just
want to put on record my thanks to the
the executive members who who attended
and the directors and Public Health
Officer for for you know providing an
absolutely detailed response to all of
those questions and the fact that they
have very little time to sort of
research the questions I think they did
a fantastic job and and and all the
committee were really pleased in the way
that we'd got the answers and I think
it's a good way to do that scrutiny
rather than having presentations on a
particular subject you know to to have
something in advance as you know so some
written reporting in advance from the
executive so that we can actually
highlight the questions that we want to
we want to do but and finally just
moving forward our next meeting is on
the 1st of July and it was agreed by the
members that we would like to look at
the budget and the local economy as a
main item and looking at how this crisis
is hitting our budget and we will be
asking the executive to Barak to provide
an initial written overview
of the budget and hopefully the
executive member and director and even
maybe yourself if you wish to come
leader to that meeting and lastly I
think the members are keen to look at
what had actually changed through this
crisis and and what has worked well in
the council and as an example of that
you know the the the six community hubs
that have worked really really well you
know how can we look at that for the
future you know and how we can develop
those kind of things and I think the
same will go for remote working and and
transport and so on so that we're
looking ahead and not just you know
looking backwards and so that's you know
that that's just a quick overview but we
have you know presented a report written
report which o the executive executive
members will have thank you Andrew
thanks council act and really helpful
update on what have been some unusual
arrangements running okay I'm turning to
item six on the agenda which is
glyphosate usage in Trafford and
pronounced councillor answered to
introduce that course please okay Thank
You leader doe pleased to bring in this
report here today this is one of the
area's I've been involved with for a
number of years now as some members will
be aware of off and it's a I've been
hands-on pretty much with all this work
over the trials and I was seeing it all
I think really pleased to being what's
effectively a really good news story
here today and those you will be aware
that in the boy talks about the trials
that have taken place over year
including water foam butane mechanical
as well as taking advice on some of the
other items that been used elsewhere was
as well so it's quite been quite a
comprehensive period and I think one
should see as well as that this should
actually be seen
as a like report talking about phase one
of the trials I think the next step from
this report will actually be effectively
phase two of the trials where we
actually saw implementing some of this
work to see how effective it actually is
none of this things may not be as
purchasing where previously but I think
it's getting used the way some things
may look in the future as well so I'm
really positive with that now if you
look at some of the trials and that one
with with that with actually hosted
meetings with friends apart screw
crusher I think that that went down
quite well I think
parks were overwhelmingly supportive not
discontinuous at use in park letting I
set an important bill pleased to say
that we are stopping issues completely
in parks altogether there wasn't using
parts limited but I thought we pleased
to say that I've now gone I will go
completely by the board the dis work
with a number of methods that including
there including some mechanical
equipment which are Tina and actually
can really lead claim whole sections of
footpaths in parks I think it's really
an amazing piece of kit and that one
there I was a part when we got of course
is in hard space well it's actually much
harder where weeds can be damaging they
can take all before past completely I've
seen the novel seen pictures where you
can get rights from the fissile ones
that grow as high as myself and I think
that they can really pass and obviously
any youngsters that they walking down
footpaths with bare arms or legs are
susceptible to those sorts of things
so a close of course damage to
infrastructure around the footpath
damaging that lifting paving stones
dungeon rails so I think it is something
we have to take seriously on that one
and this Camille please that results
this trials roughly going to be I would
have been trying something called new
weeks it's out and they're poor but
obviously because of colvett this year
it's actually really affected all that
so it's really disappointing that were
actually can tackle this particular
point to it well obviously we want to
continue to take this every serviced way
and therefore would come up with dishing
instead of doing to lots of glyphosate
or in the air we're actually going to be
using the one now that has resulted and
also some members of contacted myself
across the different groups to say about
the state of the earth for passport
because we are going to be doing the use
the one you circle I have to say it's
actually men we've actually had it
serviced
in the early part of late spring or
early summer we've had to defer all the
weeds are actually going significant way
or fairly significantly to actually make
swell up the earth when we spot these
there's actually something to adhere to
it doesn't stay on it once it's gone on
date it will vanish after a period of
time so if no weeks of presence it
wouldn't have any effect at all and of
course will continue to medicate this we
sort be having meetings and discussions
about taking this ball forward and how
we can actually medicate she was
completely no obviously uh I think must
clear on this one is that glyphosate
yourself this actually will be time
limited won't grow another the companies
have produced his parents and licensed
to sell it actually a no it's on a on a
period of time we'll be limiting its use
so they've been producing lots of items
I've been discussing with one company
obviously they are producing stuff that
some of it isn't ready to go yet but no
doubt at the moment that that the
timeline is set for I would say this
will actually come into play and they'll
actually I'm sure make these products
available and we can actually move on
with this I'm really pleased to her via
move this report today it's really
proactive and it's a really some great
news story there for communities and
justified obviously aside of the what's
in there port as well obviously we are
said that if any community organizations
but once work with us to actually
allocate excuse on that particular
street and say that over we're more than
happy to work with those groups as well
but so with that later I'll actually
leave that before and actually wait for
any questions Thank You Clara said about
any questions or comments from members
of the executive if so could you raise
your hand please
and again if you can raise your hand on
the participant bottom because I can't
see everybody on the screen if you might
come in more widely and I have
councillor cockiness
please thank you you know I wanted to to
welcome the progress that has been made
and this was a motion first by the green
group and forged by the Lib Dems and
sometime back and we're really pleased
to see this is having impact on the
ground and Trafford we're in the middle
of the sixth great extinction and the
that we are actually continuing to put
out substances are actually contributing
to this problem rather than trying to
stop it it's is really an issue for a
lot of people and I understand the delay
about the Nomex Joule trial with the the
covert crisis and also particularly
wanted to welcome the expectation that
from 2022 on we're likely to find some
cheaper options available and I just
know two point six point two I think it
was and there's an expectation that the
no-mix
will take us down to about seventy
percent of what we have been previously
using and wondering how confident we are
in that expectation is that based on
data from elsewhere or is it possible
that no mix will turn out to be less
reliable than we had thought
that's their answer do you want to
respond to those points please yes sir
thank you yeah I'm not particular last
point never yeah I mean obviously we'll
be monitoring its use but it does have a
so it's on record that the 70% takes
into it use all aspects of the report
there so obviously it is possibly
something we'll be monitoring and we can
actually be giving me port back to
members but as you point out there this
isn't again the matter it's only the
beginning this is simply a progress
report in that sense of it as you may
know we're also you may not know her
they said this I've been looking at glad
to say and I've been raising questions
and open up counsel for several years
now because of some men women around so
it's not a case of it's just in its
convenes that's not quite true I've been
raising this matter for some time now I
sort of took on this for all of us
should be able to get into it get the
work started so obviously welcome the
support of all parties on this one it's
in everybody's interest to actually do
this but I think it's something that
residents cross about well welcome as
well they look so hunky leader I'm glad
that some you know the glyphosate is
being looked at seriously but you know
with regard to getting rid of such of
weeds and stuff and in sort of parks and
wasteland
and it's it's been done in it you know
in a rather sort of
unkind way to wildlife can I give an
example of Kingsway Park where the edges
of the park have been hacked back so
you've actually got rid of the habitats
for the foxes that live there and the
hedgehogs so in in a way you're doing
one thing with one hand and another
thing with another and third any comment
on that
yeah and that may not be related to a
workaround rather say it's obviously if
the council will actually send me the
details can obviously have that look I'm
suspecting that may be more in the way
of the work they do round every spring
before nesting season comes in to
actually cut back the foliage that's
grown over the winter period so a
specialist pulling part not a lot but I
said well if it's being too severe and
it will quite happy to look at that and
actually take that for national ace well
that doesn't happen again so yeah I will
bring councillor button and then
councillor Jerome if I can ask everybody
please to raise their hand in the
electronic way on the participant list
but counselor but any chair and it's a
question just to ask whether there's
been any consultation with the seven
members of you know the members of the
public I notice on the on face 31 it
mentions doing the stakeholders and
partners and members and that but I
thought maybe members of the public are
going to be consulted on this as well or
have there been accualy de menthe we've
obviously had extensive consultations
with friends groups and so forth
I've done a full public consultation is
yet I mean that's something we could
consider in the future although I
imagine it's going to be overwhelmingly
supported in any case I think we're
quite to consider all options around
that thanks to council as I've said for
being so open and communicating all the
way from the making of the report and
because I think it's an excellent
that you've made over the year I just
wanted to know will there be further
trials with companies such as weeding
tech who do the foam stream any of those
planned in the near future
Thank You leader I think you counsel
John could please send me over that
information will actually happily look
at all options at the moment say we're
in part two the twelves put in the
Pascal implicit applications of the work
we've done so far well it devour
potential all those sources of things to
look at I think we're more than happy to
do so
thank you okay thanks so yes cancer
upside thank you from from me as well
the work that you've done on this I know
it's something that you have taken a lot
of first munch I said over a number of
years so it's pleasing to see progress
in that area could I ask members of the
executives are happy to approve the
recommendations within the report take
yourselves off you just a confirm please
thank you okay
item seven is education as a village
green I will ask counsel the right to
introduce and then I will also bring
Patel in if you'd like to come in as
well counsel the right Thank You leader
this is a really positive paper which
sets out our intention to designate term
loss as a village green the friends
group are some very exciting and
ambitious plans for the site and this
designation will help to realize those
plans and give the community some
security over its future it will also
protect against unone unwanted
developments of this at the site for an
alternative uses the friends group have
been successful in receiving the ten
thousand pound ground from social
investment fund and some of the short
and long term aspirations for the
Friends of term loss include new Sinese
around the site improved connectivity
with surrounding areas are you're
walking cycling paths improve sporting
facilities new trapeze and biodiversity
projects a wetland wildflower meadow in
a waterlogged area and improved toilet
facilities we expect the application
process to take between one and three
months
the application has been made and I move
this report Thank You leader Thank You
counselor right counselor
it's how anything to add with your audio
in mind I mean just just briefly it's a
very positive report which we should all
welcome it's Testament really to the
tenacious work of the Friends of turn
Moss look forward to working with them
engaging positively to develop their
exciting plans for the site's no welcome
the report thank you thank you were
there any questions or comments
remembers of the executor No okay any
questions or comments more widely if you
could raise your hand cancel olam thank
you very much leader and I think of the
options that are presented then this is
the right one in terms of the status of
the legal status of the land and I'm
aware and I know that what is not
covered in the scope of this report is
the work of the Friends of turn moss and
councillor Patel has just referred to
that so I think my comment is rather
similar to the expectations that we have
with the Friends of George carnal center
again we you know we have a group of
very active residents who want to do a
great deal here this is quite a big
acreage and I suppose my comments is
that you know we will need to work very
closely with the Friends of tournaments
and I'm just wondering whether given the
importance of that site in our
well-being strategy and and so on
whether the executive will be receiving
a report at some stage about the plan
that the friends have in for that site
and how this council is able to to help
them thank you
thanks counselor I certainly think
moving forward given the as you said a
significant size a bit of the skeptic
side but also the you know scope
you
you
to allow the executive to remain cited
and posted on dressing
hello probably miss the last 30 seconds
of that yeah
break it up
Oh
Rosen Andrew you hear me now
yes you can
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
people hear me
Oh
you just made us on offers a difference
[Music]